there's a global investigation underway
this morning into how a prominent
businessman escaped from house arrest in
Tokyo
former Nissan Chairman Carlos goon was
being held on financial misconduct
charges when he fled Japan and ended up
in his native Lebanon Elizabeth Palmer
is in London where she's following this
the remarkable downfall of a man once
considered an icon of the auto industry
Elizabeth good morning from icon to a
kind of infamy here the story seems too
incredible to be true you know it could
be a movie in fact it probably will one
day be a movie this is the man who until
2018 was really a rock star of the
business world and he has pulled off in
the last few days one of the most daring
and mysterious disappearing act of
modern times in spite of being under
almost constant surveillance by the time
Japanese prosecutors arrived at Carlos
Gaughan's house in Tokyo on Sunday the
man himself had vanished he flew from
Japan through Istanbul on a private jet
and then on to Lebanon where friends say
he's holed up in a house in Beirut so
how did gone who's around five foot six
slip away there are claims that he
escaped with a band was playing in his
building at the time that he hid in a
double bass case if so it would be a
dramatic turn and what had been a
spectacular career Carlos Cohen was a
Titan in car manufacturing CEO of both
Nissan and Japan and Renault in France
he rubbed shoulders with heads of state
and was considered a visionary until in
2018 Japanese authorities arrested him
for financial misconduct the affair grew
into a scandal in Japan which hurt both
Nissan's brand and its business
meanwhile gone had posted more than
eight million dollars in bail and was
waiting for his trial in Tokyo under
video surveillance with no access to
computers or his passports his lawyer
June Ichiro hironaka told reporters he
was dumbfounded by his clients escape
though gone had made it clear he didn't
trust the Japanese courts the argument
that he's been making is that he's
getting an unfair trial he's been
streeted he's been denied access to his
wife etc for the moment Beirut looks
like a safe haven for gone who's from a
Lebanese family in Lebanon he is much
admired as a local boy who made very
good and now turns out to be an escape
artist to Interpol has now issued a
request for the Lebanese police to
arrest gone though so far there's been
absolutely no action on that request and
his lawyers have announced that he'll
hold a news conference in Beirut next
Wednesday where we may actually get to
hear whether or not he did escape in a
double bass case very interesting stuff
Elizabeth Palmer force in London thank
you yes he'd rather be on the run and
face the financial misconduct I guess he
didn't feel like he could win but as you
were saying I think in Japan the
conviction rate is like 99 percent The
Wall Street Journal reported you of
indictments ninety nine percent of the
people are convicted and he and he said
he couldn't get a fair trial there but
you mean it is a little alarming when
someone is powerful he is is decides to
run from justice
you